what's the main reason you left Islam I
don't think it's a logical reason bro I
why I went for Islam No no why did you
leave Islam like what's the main no it's
not a logical reason it's not it was it
was a process of slowly what no what
what was it there has to be something
cuz I don't think it's logical cuz we've
discussed a logical no I I think I still
I still don't believe in Free Will I
chose no I I don't choose to believe it
I believe it did you choose to think but
that's not free will that's the
determinist wait wait but opposite of
that look I'm a dependent being yeah I
need food to survive I'm composed of
pieces no but you what do you mean you
need food to survive because if you will
die if I don't eat I'll die well what is
you your subconscious no me I die no no
me I'm no but your your flesh will
evaporate into into gas into so it never
disappears no no you're first level of
thermodynamics energy cannot be created
or destroyed I'm not talking about
you're talking about if I set this on
fire it disappeared no it didn't
disappear it changed it form exactly I'm
not talking about that what are you
talking about I'm talking about even if
you go with that we have a set amount of
energy within our universe even though
this first law of thermodynamics is that
energy cannot be created or destroyed
what it does is it still shows us what
that there is a set amount of energy
within our universe now if there is a
set amount of energy within our universe
why is there a set amount the set amount
shows what that is dependent dependent
good you're cleever you're smart so
you're smart man come on man Islam is
your religion yeah you're smart you're
very intelligent CU not many people
about what's he talking about energy
don't if you have a am if you have an
have a finance amount means dep that
means dependent what we're seeing is
what does the universe and all this
energy depend on it cannot be another
thing because the question that we ask
is if that depends on this what does
this depend on this depends on that then
you have the fallacy of infinite regress
meaning there has to be a point that
there everything stops some call it the
prime mover we don't use that cam yeah
we say there has to be an independent
being logically following that created
everything now from here I'll prove to
you why it's Allah so then I think it
will make more sense to you even though
we have let's let's establish this do
you agree with this so far logically
logically it makes sense I okay so I
have you in my head and I have my friend
that makes a lot of good arguments as
well and I'm your friend I'm deciding
between two and the camera is in my face
and it's it's hard to fully accept in
front of camera right now because no
that's fine but for the sake of the
argument I will accept it listen one
second I I say something listen listen
brother yeah ignore that is coming
ignore the AUD it's hard listen we turn
off if this is the issue we turn off no
it's not the issue
brother and sisters it is the winter
season in the UK today in my house my
boiler broke and the house was freezing
cold my kids are wearing jackets I'm
trying to find hating and as a father
I'm trying to make sure my kids my wife
are warm imagine the people around the
world I'm working with one om says 100%
donation policy charity who are helping
Syria Lebanon and Afghanistan people who
are freezing to death intense brothers
and sisters donate whatever you can
because today's experience with me
showed me Subhan Allah how vulnerable we
are and just made me remember those
people who are in need whatever you
donate guys even if it is 1 help those
people in those countries Charles today
you're going to be short of Islam in we
will see we will
see by the way if if the if you are
inshallah if you are convinced with our
answer if you find the truth you will
accept to be Muslim again correct yes
I've done before so I think yeah okay
that's what so let's establish this not
just based on your answer though because
I have multiple reasonings not based on
your but based on the truth yeah of
course that's you have more questions to
say yeah yeah exactly we're at your
service and I ask Allah subhana tala to
open all of our hearts inshallah and
yourself in you seem like a sincere
brother and I'm I'm sure in even if it's
not today I'm sure insh we can whatever
we say hopefully some benefits for
ourselves we'll learn from you and learn
from each other um do I have a mic no
they can pick you up you can hear me
okay yeah good all right I'll just give
a little introduction
Brothers we've come to are we in
Amsterdam is this
Amsterdam this is Amsterdam
in how how do you say how are you in
your
language how do you say I'm I'm very
good
hello or
just how how do they say ambulance in
German I don't
know gagon or something gag it sounds
like
J yeah okay so we' got uh our brother
here he's came to our talk we had a talk
here ald we're doing this Salah plus
project we're opening Salah hubs and
we're giving the Salah mats here we've
come to Masid we're talking we're going
to be talking about that we had this
brother who wanted to ask a question and
is that your friend no no I have some
friends here but he he just knowed
question yeah yeah he was very sharp
this when he said that we said we better
ask the question otherwise we're not
going to make it today Allah bless you
very important so tell us a bit about
yourself because you said you was a um a
Muslim yes and then you left Islam yes
tell us us yes so uh during Corona I
think a little bit earlier I started
binge watching a lot of videos like I
think many of you have about ali da
Muhammed hijab as well and a lot of
YouTubers they
uh it was very interesting and it helped
me convert um I was Muslim for about I
think two
years and after that I I lost touch with
Islam um how did
that very slowly it happened
veryan was gr yeah they tell
that come back stronger maybe we we will
see so yeah yeah that happened very
slowly uh just like the converting part
was also very slowly it took about 3
years
um uh for those that are interested I
think the the thing that converted me
the most or that
um over
overal most convinced of course uh was
the I think for me the Miracles of the
Quran Quran and the uh the for spelling
it from the prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam the prophecies prophecies
exactly to me that's one of the
strongest things right exactly yeah yeah
I agree with you fully yeah um and
gradually it became less and less I
started making more friends that are not
Muslim and we had talks like everybody
has and I can't say a distinct point
that made me lose Islam okay it's very
difficult okay but what are the main
thing that made you to lose Islam uh I
think the the part about Allah punishing
us I think that's one of the main
reasons for me so the punishing was one
you said free will is another yeah and
but those have connections to each other
okay what else mention like mention the
top five so we just idea sure sure so um
punishment uh Free
Will
um what about Capital punishments does
that play a role like Capital Punishment
No no he's talking about the punishment
of ask is it one of the other ones cuz
some people oh okay no no the the
punishment of uh after death after death
yes after death um within that there are
specific reasons I have um
it's hard to come to mind now okay no
problem what we'll do is we'll try to
answer the two and then the other ones
that you think of you can tell us in so
the first one you said was um uh the the
punishment of the Hereafter yeah I would
like to begin with free will I think
okay free I have it I have it laid out
in my in my head so it's my question is
based on a few uh assumptions okay so
the assumption is
um let me think
uh so God God gives us free will yeah
yeah uh God decides that my free will is
different from your free will MH okay um
no no keep it between us keep it between
hold it okay yeah car uh yeah you can
ask about that later
um those two things actually so yeah
okay so you said free will yes okay you
know you said your free will is
different than my free will yes what do
you mean by that uh what I mean by that
is um the Our Lives that we both have
are different are different oh yeah
because of external factors okay yeah uh
and I assume that the only thing that
distincts
our uh punishment will be how we use our
Free Will right oh okay and we use our
Free Will in reaction to external
factors so my father hits me I respond
to that and with my free will but it's
not my fault my father hits me or that I
how do I say this I I understand saying
saying you're saying that for example
there's different consequences that have
different reaction and cause and effect
yes okay yeah so so what I would say is
this here like when it comes to free
will we all have the same Free Will in
the sense what Allah has given us the
free to make decisions okay choices
that's the same how we react to that is
that it's Upon Us MH yes so it's it's
and of course Allah has created the
action and all those other factors but
we have free will and at the same time I
think the question is if Allah knows
then he knows everything and knows where
I'm going to go then how thises free
will work mhm oh that doesn't matter to
me I understand the yeah yeah
determinism about how it's yeah so you
have no problem with that no no problem
with so your question is not that if
Allah knows where I'm going MH that's
not your issue right no it it it's my
issue about I don't see a way where um
where our Free Will is all the same but
our punishment
um is very different but isn't that
based on like good that we do like for
example argument let's suppose you um
you have opportunity let's say we both
have £200 in our account you decide to
spend half of that on orphans I decide
to spend it on um drinking alcohol um
don't you think that the Free Will that
you had and you acted on doing a good
deed and the Free Will I had and acted
on doing an evil deed and the the end
result should not be the same because
you've done a good deed and you should
be rewarded for that I done a bad de I
should not be rewarded for that uh no
because I think the Free Will that I
have and the Free Will that you have
that we all share I
think um because you Cho sorry in your
story you chose the correct option right
like the good option you chose the bad
option you did the good option I did the
bad option yeah I believe that be I
chose the bad option because um I was
raised and I experimented life in a
certain way to make me make that CH
maybe it's you know the the brother
the brother wanted to say basically that
our free will as well is based on
our our Free Will is based on our
experiences as well meaning that we do
things according to our experiences now
for example they did an experiment they
put a wallet with money on the floor mhm
and then they saw some people they
walked by they didn't do about nothing
about it some people they came they took
they look left and right they took it
and put them then their Po and they run
away with it yeah some people they
picked it up and they were looking for a
police officer to hand it to them so
those people they worked according to
their Free Will am I
right
well I don't believe in free will but uh
in so that's another problem then then
based on what they have done the one the
one who who choose to steal it and the
one who choose to give it back to the
owner mhm now here is there one force
dealing with them or multiple forces
multiple forces which forces dealing
with how they choose yeah um everything
that I that they have experienced in
life yeah but they choose they choose to
do something am I right that's the
meaning of the free will to choose to do
something the meaning of the free will
to choose yourself to do something now
here the person who has who for example
the one who choose to hand it out to
hand it back to the owner M yeah he
choose to do this not necessarily there
are some people who are actually who
brought up in a in a bad from in a bad
situation maybe it could be in a bad
families could be this but they have
this kind of morality they have this
kind of a good morality to say you know
what this thing doesn't belong to I need
to retain it and we we have experienced
where where does that come from then
that's that's the what do you think
where this come from if this not from
the influence of the people well if it's
from the influence of the people it's
it's you cannot be judged upon that
because it's from people if it's not
from the influence of the people then
from where that inner morality yeah it
is from the influence of the people no
I'm saying to there are some people I'm
saying I'm saying to you examples who
literally people who lived in a in a in
in amongst gangsters they lived there
but they choose not to do things yeah
they prefer not to do things they have
they didn't accept the things that's
happening now those ones where this
where this came from so they had no I'll
give I'll well there's always an you
never know what the influence is myself
as an example like in JIA I used to
chill with actual like fullblown
gangsters I was not one of them like I
was just I was like someone like I would
have a different Jia but they would sell
drugs class A drugs I used to be around
them and I would never go near it I I
would say look I don't want to be
involved I don't want to touch it not
cuz of FL it's just I just thought to
myself morally it's not correct they did
not have an impact an influence on me a
lot of people fall for influence like
when you're young I didn't a lot of my
friends would smoke weed I just said you
know what I don't want to you get it so
the she is saying that um if that's the
case we understood from your question is
if that influence should be there should
influence him to get involved I group
but I didn't so how would you what would
you say to that because I should have
been influenced um I would say to that
that even if it's the Free Will from
Allah that influenced it
yeah the Free Will that he gave you yeah
you
used yeah yeah so I I use that free will
say no to it yeah so imagine if you said
yes to it yeah and you would be punished
for it yeah because I would use my free
will again to say yes to it yeah exactly
but the Free Will that he gave you maybe
someone in another scenario he doesn't
respond to it because his because he
didn't use his free will the blame is on
who so it's not based on the influence
but based on the decision he makes on
his Free Will so the one yeah but the
but the decision he makes on his Free
Will is based on all his past
experiences that influences it you said
not necessarily I'm saying to you it's
not yeah yes je he's a hard determinist
determinist is basically but you see the
problem with hard determinism is because
it's very interesting atheist come to us
and say you got the issue of God willed
everything we say well atheist you have
hard determinism hard determinism means
the following if today a for example if
today somebody comes and starts in front
of a judge and he's a hard determinist
he says the judge say you killed four
people MH the judge cannot persecute him
because he will say external factors
influence me to do that I am not
responsible for this I agree with him
okay so okay good problematic do you see
what no I don't think it's problematic
okay so then if I come and say I'm going
to kill you today and it's not my fault
is that my am I can I go scotf free can
I walk out this door today by killing
you and saying I'm a hard determinist
and I believe factors in my life played
the role in me doing that and I should
not be blamed and I should walk free
well what do you mean with blamed
because I do think you should be locked
up because if we if we don't lock you up
then other people will see that they can
do that as well okay but it's hard deter
but they hard the same thing but we have
to in society we have to create some
security and that we do it even though
it's not your fault because everything
leads to so the other but I can use that
excuse and say I canot but I agree with
it I agree with the excuse okay I cannot
be okay but if you say that a rapist a
killer a Hitler M St Mong staning that
killed millions of people will come and
say there's hard determinism we believe
all these facts payroll I'm not in
control I didn't do it yes I did the
action but it wasn't me so then we say
you're going to have to lock up
everybody and anybody because what
happens is all of them are going to say
I'm sorry all of these other factors he
done it we got the encourage to us you
get but but not if we we lock people up
and then they but then they don't do it
that's that's the whole point then they
don't do it even though if they know
selfer like they really determinist but
now that's also determined now you're
going to look up everybody yeah it's a
reaction reaction and that's all life is
to to me at least Happ this chaos so if
it was just if it was just pure
determinism then what happens is bro
every action like today like for example
if I was to hit you I would say sorry
about I didn't do it it was just a
reaction of it's just hard determinism
and things were wi in that way and what
happens is you have no kind of no but if
you if you would do it on purpose then
it's no no but how how do you know it's
on purpose because you're a hard
determinist there is no purpose or
chance there's things just happened it's
not about you did that no no because I
do believe you can think about something
and change your actions no that's all
free will to me sorry I'm not I don't
want to shout
sorry is it's not free will because
everything that happened in your life
leads up to a moment
where you think yeah you think about it
maybe you change your actions but just
because you think about something
doesn't mean it's your free will it
means that something has caused you to
think about it yes and that external
thing causes you to then make a move
okay so but then so it's still external
good what I'm saying is if that is the
case right now what is stopping me from
killing you that's sorry for the bad
example I'm just saying what is stopping
me right now from the like let me tell
you what's stopping me okay what's
stopping me is that my religion tells me
that I should not kill an innocent Soul
do you get it and if I was not religious
I would still say this guy's done
nothing for me why would I kill him or
harm him so what I'm saying is those are
things that has been taught to me so now
if I decide to say you know what I'm
just going to kill him for what reason I
don't know then of course I should be
locked up so what I'm saying is I have a
free will to say should I no that's not
reasonable I do believe you have you get
it okay good if you have free will then
you're compatibilist compa Bel and hard
deter but I think we miss I don't think
we agree upon the same free will because
I do believe you can make a choice I can
choose now to to drop my phone right I
can choose now to um to kill you
but it's still the Free Will it's still
the Free Will that you made that you
use hold on yeah the Free Will that you
use yes is uh it's still based upon
external factors that happened earlier
in your life so you can say you have
free will but you I believe you cannot
say that someone can be uh let's say
eternally punished for something they do
out of an external reason right let me
tell you something there's something
there are a few things which is adding
to this yeah firstly we are not
neglecting that there will be influence
about certain things and factors that
could influence the person to do
whatever they do course and we have a
story that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he mentioned about a man who
killed 99 people and this due to his
upbringing due to the to the to the to
the people around him yeah and he came
to someone who a Pious person and he
said to him is there any way that I
could repent yeah he he's feel he's
feeling guilt the guilt feeling M made
him to to go to this person to ask him
if there is repentance he said if you K
not people there is no way you could
repent so he killed him so then become H
but still the feeling of guilt is still
in him so he went to aola then the schol
he looked at his situation he said you
live amongst people who are people who
are people evil people of killing so
leave them and move to another area
where the people are Pious and worship
Allah with them until you die so on the
way he died yeah on the way there here
had the angel of punishment they they
were in dispute should should they take
his soul and the angel of of Mery they
said should they take take the soul his
soul so dispute they went back to Allah
they said he was he the angel of they
said he killed n he killed 100 people
mhm the angel of Mercy they said
actually he was he repented then Allah
said if he was closer to the land where
the people the pious ones then the angel
of Mercy will take him Allah knows his
sincerity he was sincere to repent MH
from this Allah has moved his body to be
closer to the land where the people of
the P people and the end of men took his
soul from the story we learn few things
we learn sometimes yes could be the the
factors the things around us could
influence us our Behavior with our
action but at the end of the day the
point when the people is when the person
is taking that decision at that point
yeah yeah to do and not to do they could
all the background and all of these
things that point here it is his free
will to choose to do it now there is no
one can say and we are born in our
nature or in our innate we are we we
Allah says in the
Quran that Allah showed him the guidance
either the person grateful or ungrateful
so in our nature we are inclined to
worship Allah we are inclined to believe
in God Etc but our community and our
society and the things around that will
influence us to do different things
these things these are facts yeah you
agree with me on that on that the only
the only thing we we say here which is
that's why which is missing in you which
to say the point of the taking that
decision here there where you are when
you take that decision either you are
blame worthy for the things if it's
wrong or you are praiseworthy if you did
something right at the point where you
are taking the decision we're not
neglecting the factors around you or NE
neglecting that everything happens in
this universe under the of nothing
happens in his kingdom without his
permission without him allowing it and
part of the of it's part of our faith as
Muslims yeah including people killing
each other by the way at the same time
here the point of taking the decision
that point the person either prais
worthy or blame worthy the point of
taking the decision and you know and I
know the point when you said you want to
drop the phone at this point you know
and I know at this point when you are
dropping this phone you know that that
point it is your free will did it I I
don't yeah I don't agree but I I'm
saying to you now here if you don't have
the ability to hold the phone mhm that
means that Free Will is not there even I
mean to choose that to do this thing
meaning all the experiences and
everything influence you to think about
and you know for example while holding
the phone before I dropped it I know the
con I know I'm going to throw it here
it's going to be on the carpet it's not
a solid floor I know my phone is
protected and all of this in my mind
before I'm doing it yeah all these
things in my mind if it's if if if the
phone doesn't have a protector if the
floor is solid I may not do it because
I'm going to break my phone yeah so
these are factors previous factors to do
it I'm I'm saying this but still at the
point of taking that decision at that
point here you have a choice that's why
here what what do you mean with a choice
because you don't throw it on the on the
Rocks because it will break yes so you
have a choice but your choice has
consequences which you will listen to
just as your have a consequen exactly
that's what say just as you know he said
if he knows the fact of that if he threw
into the fire will burn just the way we
don't do bad days because we know
there's the fire but but you well who
knows I don't know no no no but if if if
it exist so what we're saying is the
same principle applies I'm not going to
throw my phone into the fire cuz if I
know the consequences cuz that's my free
will okay if I find in the fire I'm
going to lose my phone um and I'm going
to be you know losing money and the same
thing is this I'm not going to do a bad
deed because if I do a bad deed I know
that there's a consequence but you said
for example before we continued you said
that sorry can I can I interrupt you uh
do you believe then that Free Will is
only there when you have a religion no
no no free will no because no but
because everyone has free will if you
have free will you're not Muslim yeah
but but I'm Bound by the consequences
that's the point what bound consequences
of your actions of every action and and
for sure if I'm not religious because
then it's just worldly uh consequences
yeah exactly so we all have free will so
what we're saying is that everyone has
free will me as a religious person I am
Bound by the Shar that's given by God
Almighty you are bound by your liberal
worldview the only difference is I
follow God's law you follow man law okay
and yeah but the okay wait so you you
are bound by the consequences of Shar
and of uh of the Hellfire right yeah and
you are bound by the the laws that you
follow the like the country's government
yeah and sometime but some sometimes I
don't listen what don't yeah I don't
what I'm just saying like we're
both under the Shar of Allah for example
Allah has two like we actually learned
with mmed this year there's there's one
law that Allah has is for everybody the
Muslims and the non-muslims yeah and
there's one that Allah has Shar that
Allah loves call the
UN and and the the the one that Allah
God Almighty loves for us so what I'm
seeing is the difference between us you
like you know some people atheist come
to me and say oh you religious people
you believe and I say you also follow
religion goes no I don't I go yes you do
I go okay no who created heavens and
earth Mother Nature I go yeah that's
your God I said what LO do you I said
can you eat pork he goes yeah I go I
can't eat pork I go the only difference
is you can eat whatever you like I can't
eat certain stuff so you follow a
specific Lord I follow Lord the only
difference is you worship a false false
god which you say it's Mother Nature big
bang I say it's Allah you come and say I
can have sex before marriage I can drink
alcohol I can do this I go good I can't
well I can get married yes I don't drink
alcohol I drink orange juice sometimes
pin one of
course most Al okay so the only
difference is this you follow a
legislation and even some of them are
say you even have a prophet they go who
is I go Richard Dawkins you follow him
oh he said this Blind Faith we say we
have the same we have the same thing
with the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him so there is nothing much different
we just follow different set of laws
yeah but but you have in your worldview
you have given you have been given to
the correct set of rules we
morality we have objective morality from
God on no no but I mean the you have you
have been given religion that allows you
to make the correct uh decisions with
the Free Will that you believe to have
right that's why we're saying you should
be a Muslim because then we have correct
objective morality from God that's the
reason why you're in this dilemma
because what happens is when you take
God out the picture you are like for
example your brain is a byproduct of
evolution let's say m i can't I can even
say to you I mean how can we even trust
what you're seeing or how can we trust
what I'm seeing because we're a
byproduct of like for example if I was
to throw this in the fire and throw a
human being in the fire what's the
difference rearrangement of atoms this
one and human being that's why Hitler
and people who are communists atheists
they killed the millions of people you
know why it's Eugenics meaning these
people what's the it's just an
evolutionary process there is no God
nothing
call carbon dirt it's just carbon dirt
it's just a rearrangement of atoms when
he dies or when I thr this in the fire
it's the same thing there's no value to
human life in Islam when you have
objective morality we say no this is a
human being this is a soul this is
someone that has something to offer as a
being you become a human but in the
atheist perspective you're just a
byproduct like for example that's why
Hitler used to kill people who are
disabled he said this is the lowest
class of the law he get rid of him it's
causing us problems he has nothing to
offer so what happens is when you have
objective morality from God Almighty
everything yes yes so you know when you
said if we have hard determinism hard
determinism means the following you
cannot question any action I do if today
I was to kill four people you cannot
come and say that sply I say no because
I believe in hard determinism other
factors influen this I should not be
locked up this is this is the hard
determin but what do you mean locked up
as in as a punishment can for as no no
but you see a pun punishment as um as
the way that I didn't Allah punishes
people no I didn't do it but whatever
action an evil person done he says I
didn't do it that's what when you write
a book when you write a book can't he
has important point he has important he
said so you said you believe in this
hard determinism yeah yeah which means
everyone has to be the same
understanding correct sorry everyone has
to have the same understanding like
youis let's say yeah because that's how
it is so meaning the same concept so if
someone go and kill 10 people believing
in her because this I'm I'm forced to do
that these are my things so the other
one they shouldn't be judging him
because they had determin because that's
that's how well yeah I agree you can
judge him I study psychology and we so
there's no vision is fully about uh what
what causes people to that means there
no that means there is no l it it means
that we have to still punish them we we
still have to punish them because if
they don't then they're going to do it
again so we have to punish them so they
learn from it based on what what do you
mean based on what based on what you
punish them but it's not their based on
the action that they did not because why
they did it because of the action
because the action of murder you can you
can collectively as a society say it's
bad it's not it's not objectively bad I
know I don't believe in I agree I agree
if there is no fault that means there is
no punishment you know you said based on
the action they did there is no they did
they they did it they were caused to do
it by other factors but they still good
now how they how am I to blame if other
factors like if I write a book I can't
say wrote by Ali dawa you I I agree you
are not to blame but it's the only it's
the only way we can live in society it's
the only way so we have to punish him so
he knows the next time I'm not going to
do it and so his friends know I'm not
going to do it ever but it's different
from the punishment from Allah what you
said now is very interesting because
that means you are going against the
principle of hard determinism by saying
we have to jump out of that belief
because if we go in that belief chaos
because you said if we punish him
because we have to because other going
to Beed yeah so that means you are not
accepting this hard determined worldview
and saying we have to lock you up
because if we don't lock you up there's
going to be chaos yeah but that's that
goes against hard determinism because
what you're doing is you're stepping out
and saying you if someone comes and says
sorry guys external factors or whatever
um you're going to lock me up but if
everyone followed that there will be
chaos so now you're going out of your
principles to apply law no no no no no
no cuz why do you say after by the way
by the way have to do this otherwise by
the way by the way how come how come by
the way by the way because that causes
him to think about his actions and do
something else so we still cause him he
still has no choice want to be exper
motives influen that you went through
makes you decide that he shouldn't be
locked up then what happens then there
could be but if we happens then what
happens then if you decide and say no
actually actually know it's not his
fault if well if we all collectively
decide that as the society if we all he
could say he could say
criminal the criminal could say is
actually you the punishers you made me
to do that because it's part of that
which means they have to punish
themselves before him what will happen
if yeah yeah if we collectively say that
that's true then that's true because
that is in U determinism that is the the
that's the morality we don't have
objective morality I agree I agree I've
seen your video about it now this means
this yeah just means this there is
fullblown chaos but it's not because we
live in a no it's not I'm talking I
don't I don't believe they're full-blown
chaos I'm not talking about IDE you're
talking about this world I'm saying if
everyone was a hard determinist there
will be chaos correct I no I don't
believe so no okay but if everyone says
he's not guilty he killed his people but
I I really believe that we don't there
there might be a chance we will but we
don't I'm talking about your view of
hard determinism let's live in that
world we want to live in a world the
planet Earth is not called Planet it's
called Planet hard determinism but we
still make laws about about why do we
make laws why to prevent people from
doing certain things okay but where's
this coming from well a lot of the law
these laws come from religion and that's
partly a good thing but we still we can
still create new laws and uh debate
about it and vote on them so you and
make what laws that everybody agrees
with all subjective do you see what
happens when we have we don't have
objective morality everyone comes and
says I think we should do this I think
we should do that maybe we should do
this maybe should and I think we could
could collectively decide which is in
that moment for to us the best let me
tell you yeah I know he has a good point
in the nazzi system in Germany they
voted and then they when in Collective
you know voting they decided that the
Jews they have to be executed they have
to kill the all the even the what you
call it the what call it the Jews and
and and other the lower class lower
class and then they they accepted this
so this part of the law system what do
you think of this yeah so so I think
that's a I think that's a very good
example of what you said if everything's
turn to turns to chaos exactly yeah so
that's good what would you do like if
you was if you lived in Nazi Germany you
would have to go with the system I think
if I lived in na Germany I would be
killing the Jew yeah I think I would be
I think because 99% of us would all I'll
be we I would maybe you maybe because
you follow the rules of and some good
and some good Germans and by the way not
just some Muslims who are in France who
hid who hid Jews fake yeah not just I
Muslims in in France who hid Jews in
when German entered France they hid Jews
in their houses jeez their lives their
the lives of their family to protect
them there are some good Germans well in
Germany who lived in that system they
decided not to go Germans who decided
not to go with that system and even some
of them being killed by the Nazis
because they decided to go against it
which means basically your hard deter
they get out of the from the window why
why why why does this
disprove let's get the definition of
hard determinism right because I
accepted it but maybe what what's your
definition ofis have a special one sorry
have your own one can can I don't know
I'm not ask a no no let's see let's mean
with determinism what do you mean by
determinism that that everything is
already determined even though yeah yeah
there's no free will do you believe in
God or not no okay good as a hard
determinist you have to believe in God
because if if there determinism who is
the
determiner if if you say for example
there's hard determinism meaning that
there was a point of like there's a
cause and those causes are based on
other it's like domino effect yeah who
there has to be a determin there has to
be one yeah yeah okay I've made that
yeah I know what you mean so there has
to DET if you go with the argument
determinism you have to agree that there
was a determiner that started well if
that deter what do you mean just
something that's no a being has started
it all you what is a being good so for
example let's start with because you
know I you believe in God but not Islam
okay you don't believe in God let me
make it very simple okay let me use the
argument ofy yeah because you're an INT
intelligent person yeah you accept that
look there's three types of existence
yeah there is impossible existence there
is possible existence and there's
necessary existence yeah and impossible
existence is um can we have you agree
with this by the way yeah I I'll give
the three examples the first one I've
heard it but I don't understand it fully
okay I'll tell you the first one is this
can we have a triangle
square of of what a shape can we have a
triangle
square a square which is looks like
triangle yeah can you can you have
something that's triangle or a square
like Circle a circle a circle square no
okay good why because a triangle has
three sides A square has four sides okay
so you can't have a triangle square it's
an impossible existance yeah correct
good now we have two left which is what
possible existence and necessary
existence possible existence is wait
what what was what was the other named
so necessary existence possible
existence and impossible existence
impossible existence is to have
oxymorons Triangle Square okay a
triangle has three sides can you explain
how that's related to uh God or I'll
tell you how so I'm talking about there
are three types of existence the first
one is an impossible existence the
second one is then that's not an
existence right so so we're saying impos
meaning it doesn't exist yeah okay so a
triangle square we can't have that we'll
say bye-bye to that yeah yeah okay good
so the two that we're left with is
possible existence and necessary
existence now the possible existence is
me you our planet Earth our
gravitational force the Sun the galaxies
and the universe these are the things
that rely on something else to survive
for example I am a contingent being I
depend on other factors to survive I
need water I need food I need to sleep I
need many other factors our planet Earth
relies on the gra ational Force the Sun
the moon Jupiter which the gravitational
force that deters met that coming to
towards our planet to survive and our
solar system requires other factors to
survive we have a question now we cannot
have a infinite regress of dependent
things meaning this things relies on
this this depends on this this depends
on this if it went forever we would
never have the universe yeah so let me
ask you a question the universe do you
believe the universe is dependent or
independent I don't know okay why I
would say is the following for us
dependent is the following anything that
is composed of
pieces anything that can be any other
way and it depends on something else for
its survival now would you agree that
our universe is composed of
pieces galaxies okay would you accept
that our universe could be any other way
they could have been 4 billion less
galaxies or 5 million more galaxies good
that makes it dependent meaning okay
within itself it depends on these
factors to survive mhm okay then the
question is this if the universe is
dependent what does it depend on it
cannot depend on something else that's
dependent because then it's like well
then what does that depend on it depends
on this it has to stop at a necessary
being which is not composed of pieces
pieces cannot be any other way and is
dependent and necessary meaning he that
being is the ultimate source of the
beginning of the
universe
and uh why does he so the the natural
question would be so what causes him to
exist or what sorry what was was the
word he used so what um he's independent
inde yeah so what depends on him or what
does he depend on if he's independent
remember we said the first one was like
you kind of a square triangle yeah so
we're saying you cannot have you can't
say what does the independent depend on
because we said he's what is the
independent yeah but
but yeah he's the independent so if he's
the independent that means yeah but why
couldn't we be the dep independent
because we're dependent like for example
if today I walk and get hit by a bus I
die yeah so I'm not inde but okay get
hit by a bus so the so basically the
material that we I I need water to
survive you're depend I depend on that
like you know in in Muslim you knowah
you
remember say is one self-sufficient MH
this is what I'm talking about the
self-sufficiency I'm talking about Allah
does God this being is not depending on
anything everything depends on himh so
he's independent so we can't say he
depend because we said there's three
types of existence dependent independent
so we're saying we talked to you about
all the dependent things all of these
dependent Things We Said the universe is
dependent dependent on what the
independent being now you can come and
ask me me okay Ali let's suppose there's
independent being why Allah why not
Jesus why not ganes M you can ask me
that yeah but I yeah if you want to ask
no no I don't okay so do you accept that
there's independent
being um there has to be independent
being it's hard I I have I've looked in
this into this this matter like a lot of
times and I still can't wrap my head
around the it's very simple problem we
we cannot have an infinite regress of
dependent things there has to be a
starting point this being is independent
he's not composed of pieces he cannot be
any other way and he created all of that
as simple as that because you said the
universe is dependent and he has
attributes by the way yeah yeah no
attributes we're going to we're going to
come to now just before we go to that
we're going to come to the attributes so
for example there is no other answer
he's the independent being that created
everything and if and then I can prove
to you why it's Allah okay Pro before
you prove let's let's accept before you
go to that do you accept this before we
go further there's yeah that's it's a
difficult one you have to why is it why
is it this I give you I think because
either either you think Lally or you
think logically up to you think you
could think about dragons and that's up
to you but we're saying we're talking
about things which is logic thing yeah
MH now we said to you we said to you you
cannot have an infinite an infinite you
know uh dep depend it has to have a
starting point since it has a starting
point it should be an independent being
yeah and has certain main characteristic
but
but that's can can I say something about
the independent being to me maybe you
will explain it later that could be but
um the independent being that you are
describing to me it's like uh going out
of out of logical um how it's arent
because to me it's illogical that he can
be even independent let's say no how
Okay one second because because of what
you just said but didn't you say a
minute ago why can we not be independent
why was no no because you but you
afterwards you explained to me why we
can't be independent so why can't he why
can't he be independent he's the
opposite of look I'm a dependent being
yeah I need food to survive I'm composed
of pieces no but you what do you mean
you need food to survive because if you
will die if I don't eat I'll die well
what is you you're subconscious because
I me I'm no but your your flesh will
evaporate into into gas into so it never
disappears it never disappears first
level Dynamics energy cannot be created
or destroyed I'm not talking about
you're talking about if I set this on
fire it disappeared no it didn't
disappear it changed it form yeah I'm
not talking about that what are you
talking about I'm talking about even if
you go with that we have a set amount of
energy within our universe even though
this first low thermodynamics is that
energy cannot be created or destroyed
what it does is it still shows us what
that there is a set amount of energy
within our universe now if there is a
set amount of energy within our universe
why is there a set amount the set amount
shows what that is dependent depend good
you're CLE you're smart so you're smart
man come on man you Islam is your
religion yeah you're smart you're very
intelligent cuz not many people I about
people like what's he talking about
energy energy
have if you have an have a finance am
means dep so that means it's dependent
what we're seeing is what does the
universe and all this energy depend on
it cannot be another thing because the
question that we ask is if that depends
on this what does this depend on this
depends on that then you have the
fallacy of infinite regress meaning
there has to be a point that there
everything stops some call it the prime
mover we don't use that cam yeah we say
there has to be an independent being
logically following that created
everything now from here I'll prove to
you why it's Allah so then I think it
will make more sense to you even though
we have let's agree let's let's
establish this do you agree with this so
far logically logically it makes sense I
okay so I have you in my head and I have
my friend that makes a lot of good
arguments as well and I'm your friend
I'm deciding between two and the camera
is in my face and it's it's hard to
fully accept in front of camera right
now because no that's fine but for the
sake of the argument I will accept it
listen one second I I say something
listen listen brother yeah ignore the
coming ignore the it's hard listen we
turn off if this the issue we turn off
no it's not the issue it's not the issue
it's just it's just like this but it's a
lot of things list listen I can't accept
it fully listen listen you I wanted you
to think logically now at this moment
yeah M you have agreed that the things
the beings or the things which is
impossible you know impossible things to
exist which you accept this logically
yeah you don't need your friend to
convince this with you to you correct
yeah yeah you don't need your friend to
come actually there could be a circle
square I mean you can't the friend to
tell you do you need your friend to that
of course you need to go back to him to
ask him is there a square a square
circle no no I will not I will ask him
about a lot but not a square yeah okay
good so that's that's so this impossible
to exist yeah yeah so about the possible
things to exist which is things which is
dependent things this all the all the
things within this universe everything
is depending on on something correct you
agree with this yeah so and then after
that since you said and there is a set
amount of energy within this universe
that means it is dependent correct mhm
this you agreed with this so far if
there's a set amount of energy in the
universe then it's dependent yes yeah
after that since we since we have this
that means this set amount of energy
since this universe is dependent
depending on what something independ so
you have two options it depends on
something that's dependent or it depends
on something that's independent which
one makes more logical sense I think it
makes equal uh equal sense
okay if the universe depends on
something else that's dependent if
that's dependent what does that depend
on then well there's a chance that it
might depend on something else depend on
something else and eventually it will
depend on Independent
no sure sure what you've done is it said
it might depend on some else it
depends I'm saying to you if you want to
get it from here to here the independent
being or 500 million years later I have
no problem as long as the stopping point
is what is the independent being this
friend of yours whoever it is is he is
he an ex-muslim as well or something no
no no problem I can meet him anytime I
with you I'm laughing at my friend I so
so I can meet
him I swear I swe I would be there I
just want to ask you bro if you want the
cameras off I don't need this camera if
it's going to if it's if I can tell them
no no it's okay it's okay okay I just we
need to be comfortable bro I'm not here
the cameras I don't care about this as
long as we care about you yes I just
care about you well I don't care I just
want you to know just tell me I don't
want the cameras byebye I don't only
reason I asked that is because there's
many people that ask questions like you
and they will reach them that's the only
reason why go out yeah so now so now so
yeah you let us know what comfortable if
you want everybody out everybody will go
out yeah you're welcome if you want me
to go I'll go as well okay so I think
let Al go I think that's the easiest
option yeah I think Al should just go he
talks too much
right yeah listen to this so wait one
second establish this so you agree this
there is a there is the starting point
which is an independent being correct
you agreed on this so that independent
being has certain characteristics
correct has to it has to it's a being
has to all knowing all power powerful
powerful no before that he the universe
he he created the universe M so which
means he will the universe to come so he
has a will what do you mean he willed
the universe to come the universe cre he
started the universe yeah yeah he will
that he has a will since he has a
knowledge he has a will I have a will
since he has knowledge he has a will
sure good so he has a will because he
has knowledge good so if he has a will
he has to have knowledge if he has
knowledge they they there's power mhm if
there's power for example he has to be
all knowing MH all knowing why because
there's things happen so now what we've
done is you can when you come and say
why not J the same thing you repeated
the sorry sorry sorry yeah so what I'm
saying is those attributes now what
we're doing is we're going from theism
to theism because we're seeing for
example you know when you look at a
painting when you look at a painting I
know a lot about the painter by looking
at the picture the the painting yeah why
because I'm like wow okay first number
one yeah number one he exists number
number two he's bloody good at what he
does and number three he's
intelligent let's go subjective yeah so
we look at a painting and we we know
quite a bit about the painter so the
same thing with the universe we look at
certain things in the universe we see
DNA DNA has information correct yeah DNA
has a you know this much of DNA can have
all the information in the world you
know our planet it can be stored in a
DNA this pig yeah did you know that so
now yeah yeah our DNA has no I didn't I
didn't know okay so for example go in 5
minutes though I'm actually yeah that's
fine so what we're going to do is this
here DNA has information information
requires intelligence mhm so what we're
saying is do you see when we say he has
to be the all knowing the all powerful
this is why we say has to be
Allah that's and that's and that's the
attribute of God the attribute of God
all knowing yeah the meting all knowing
and all powerful and has a will yes and
has that thought it was all kind
yes which which answers your question
question the hell does Allah say the
Quan what will I get out ofing you do
you know
Quan Allah says what will I get out of
punishing you Allah does not want to
punish his servants this concept of
Allah is someone that wants everyone to
go Hellfire it's not the concept the
Lord that we I don't believe no I don't
believe it is so when you talked about
the punishment the punishment is there
because for those people who do evil do
you understand so just to answer your
second question have five minutes I
sorry I checked wrongly
oh I do have five minutes here say check
wrong have 10
minutes that's fine someone will come
for me in five minutes so that's why I
have to no problem we come for him if
they come for you yeah your brothers
right he's coming for you's for send me
location
challenge so what was your question
about the Hellfire yeah so about the
Hellfire I before the Hellfire by the
way did you establish this yes he's he's
brother listen you said there is an
independent being you said you accepted
this so far let alone what this what
this guy is nagging in your brain now
I'm talking about the things that the
fact that you have it now since you have
you have established this there is an
independent being that this independent
being is the one that all this universe
relies on this independent being and
this independent being has certain
characteristic that all powerful all
knowing has independent will meaning
that he is has the power to create this
universe he has the knowledge to to
create this universe and he has a will
and this will has no influence by no no
one except his own will to decide to do
things and not to do things and that is
basically the definition of God MH so if
you accept this that means you are you
are a Believer like logically forget
your friend you accept just logically do
you accept this do you accept this what
we said leave your friend who's nagging
in your brain I'm talking about now I
know um do you accept this well it's
because of the the way that you you it's
logical look it's not ask a 5-year-old
boy can say the same
no I I believe it's different I I have
believed a lot of people that convince
me an argument in a certain way and then
after I I think about it I think oh no
actually it wasn't true but right now I
do uh accept right now does it make
sense your friend your friend I don't
mind meeting tomorrow I'll anyway you
like we can meet with him I I promise
you Sor don't swear you don't
have I will meet him yes no problem yeah
just send me location we'll
see friendly discussion yeah of course
of course he no no he's he's the yeah
yeah yes hopefully we'll have a
discussion with him nothing ego nothing
that so we would arrange that yeah but
so far I would say logically you're a
smart man you know it makes sense we're
talking logically I didn't do anything
special I didn't do Hocus Pocus here I'm
just telling you logically it follows so
therefore would you accept that there
has to be a dependent being and he has
attributes yeah yeah so what would be
the next question when you said about
the
Hellfire um I think well I'm still not
done about free will but we can okay
it's it's okay we can pass it yeah but
but this to your answer of the
independent being he has to be the most
just if he's the most just it means that
he cannot punish his servants if he has
pre-ordained them to enter the fire he
has to be the all just meaning Justice
means that if he's the most merciful in
the Quran every single chapter one says
that means if he's the most merciful and
he's the most just and he's also said
I've negated Injustice to myself don't
oppress meaning if we live on this Earth
it has to be that we have free will
because otherwise that means he's going
to throw me in Hellfire to something I
didn't do but he got me to do do you see
what I'm saying but yeah that's my whole
point that's why I don't believe that's
that's what connected you back to his
attribute which is what if he is the old
just that means he has given me
faculties to make Allah says in the
Quran but what what does all just mean
all just means the following you will
never stand in front of him and say God
Almighty you um misjudge me you I'm
going to the fire because it wasn't my
fault never you know Allah says in the
Quran the people of the fire will say
they will not say Allah you wrong us
they will say please give us another
chance meaning the following when we
stand in front of God there's going to
be ultimate absolute objective Justice
that you are going to know there is no
shadow of a doubt the people are in the
fire for a good reason people are in
Paradise for a good reason there's not
going to be you know what God actually
wronged that guy Adam but I cannot be
it's impossibility it's impossible
impossible because if he is the
independent being self-sufficient and he
has these attributes if one of his
attributes he's he's the most just if
he's the most just it is impossible that
how could he throw someone in Hellfire
that doesn't deserve that it's an
impossibility because he didn't do it
how how is he the oldj when he's
throwing people into the Hellfire that
don't deserve and he gives
H yeah it does not follow you get it
that's why his attribute necessitates he
has to be the all just people in the
fire deserve the fire and also there's
going to be Muslims in the fire who did
wrong who did atrocities but they will
not be in fire forever they will do
their time and eventually will enter
okay does that make sense I want to
speak to you soon okay I have to go by
the way does but listen the everything
what we said does it make sense to you
with your own logic let alone the other
things does it make sense
um half and half ask I swear half and
half yeah
course even about one
second you know the idea is what we said
to you all these things because what
happens it it happens a lot by the way
when someone is convinced with the truth
and find the truth but they said okay
they just just wanted to turn a blind
eye about the things that they found
their own selves mhm we have established
now and demonstrated now that there is
an independent being that all this
universe relies on it yeah and on him
and this independent being is has the
certain characteristics we establish
this then why we have to reopen this
again why we have to Red discuss again
have already established it you have
already accepted it m he already
believes this he already believes I
think
no no half and half meaning those
questions cuz he said he have more
questions he's saying those ones are
covered it's just the others if I'm not
mistaken no not not not per say no also
no no he UND he understood me right so
basically you're saying you still have a
question mark on the dependent and the
attributes yeah you I I still have a
question mark on the uh on if God exists
okay what's the question mark I I can't
dive deep into it right now I are you
here for longer because I can we're here
till tomorrow what what time what time
you finish no but like tonight as well I
can come back in about half an hour
that's right okay wait for you I will
come back okay can you bring a friend I
will call him okay ask him if you can
come I will call him I don't know if
he's going to say but actually listen
what's the main reason you left Islam I
don't think it's a logical reason bro I
think why I went for Islam No no why did
you leave Islam like what's the main no
it's not a logical reason it's not it
was it was a process of slowly what no
what what was it there has to be some
cuz I don't think it's logical because
we've discussed a logical for no I think
I still I still don't believe in free
will I still don't
no no okay but what's what's we don't
have we don't have the in the absolute
will uh well I chose no I I don't choose
to believe it I believe it did you
choose to think like this but that's not
free will that's the determinist wait
wait but are you but now listen you
confuse yourself now you just contradict
now you said now I believe this and then
you said you choose to believe this no
no I said I don't choose to believe it I
believe it oh okay so that's the so you
don't believe in free will no I don't I
don't no it's fine so you don't believe
in uh you don't believe in Free Will you
believe in
determinism I don't believe yeah I don't
believe in Free Will I believe in the
okay but if we go back to necessary
being his attribute he has to be the all
just he has to be it's a necessity
that's what his NE his attributes and
necess Necessities as well yeah